c'est vrai si c'est faux la quatrième de
couverture qui peut le dire bien sûr de
singulier événements se déroulent
domaine de glenmor
le caniche blanc se comporte bizarrement
avec les gens qui en ont la garde
et ceux ci se comporte eux-mêmes des
tranches façon pour les cinq détective
et leurs chiens voilà un mystère
passionnant pour fathi une occasion de
mettre à profit son art du déguisement
pour le policeman brody c'est une autre
affaire parfaite serviable et tranquille
elle sait tout faire
cuisiner coudre danser parler à son chat
et faire du poney ses parents sont fiers
d'elle ses amis l'apprécient et bientôt
les vacances ce qui se profile mais
voilà martin en a marre là veut
conquérir sa liberté se forger un esprit
critique et fuir tante lucie et son
petit train moisi cherchant
désespérément autres comptines que le
club des cinq et fantômette elle fugue
sèche sa leçon piano et se réfugie à la
bibliothèque d'annecy ici elle est
accueillie par des professionnels du
livre des responsables du secteur
jeunesse qui lui montre des ouvrages
exceptionnels
martin et virgile martin à la montagne
martin à fukushima ici on prend les
enfants au sérieux il ya même des
oeuvres d'art mise à disposition et
bibliothécaires donc jeunesse et
patrimoine décide de conserver ses
livres jeunesse témoignages aussi de
l'édition pour les enfants depuis les
années 50 60 et il ya très peu de
volonté au niveau national on va dire et
d'intérêt pour ces éditions jeunesse à
part apparaît pour la bibliothèque de
leurs joyeuses l'heure joyeuse c'est une
bibliothèque qui avait à paris et qui
conservait qui était à destination des
enfants ont fait et maintenant qui est
transféré à la bnf donc vont rentrer
dons se font tous les ouvrages de la
bibliothèque la maison de l'enfance et
puis petit à petit nous allons y
intégrer les livres tirés des
collections de tous les secteurs
jeunesse des médiathèques dancing mais
vraiment abus dès le départ de
conservation et de consultation pour les
enseignants pour le public et aussi pour
nos collègues bibliothécaire jeunesse au
vu aussi de médiation auprès des enfants
d'utilisation pour des expositions total
of the dissent à un terrain c'est pas
parce que c'était parfois abîmés
oui les ouvrages jeunesse ont cette
particularité c'est être très utilisé et
très manipulés par les enfants donc
quelquefois ils sont très mauvais état
mais on conserve de toute façon on
essaye de retrouver ensuite des éditions
peut-être en meilleur état d'ouvragé
puiser pour ne retrouve pas mais on
conserve telle qu'elle rend jean
définitivement le mystère du caniche
blanc offert par ton plus si martin fait
faire sa carte d'abonnement et repart
les bras chargés d'imagination de quoi
arriver enfin d'autres choses qu'à être
la petite fille parfaite prince jean à
cesser la chasse
c'était génial moi j'adore elle
s'adresse en colombie les échos - et
découvertes gamme du cac
sur marmotte
[Musique]